اذا كانت هناك من صور يمكن
ان نشاهدها الان هذه صور
منظمه اوكرانيه منظمه اوكرانيه نشرت هذا
الفيديو تقول فيها ان مقاتلين عبروا
الحدود الروسيه وصلوا الى تحرير منطقه اذا
هذه صور لمنظمه اوكرانيه او مجموعه مسلحه
اوكرانيه تقول ان مقاتلين اوكرانيين عبروا
الحدود
الروسيه ووصلوا لتحرير منطقه بريانسك اذا
هذه صور كما ذكرنا متداوله لمجموعه مسلحه
اوكرانيه نشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها فيبرينس هذا العلم هو علم
النباله الذي تعتبره طبعا القوات
الاوكرانيه شعارا لها اذا هذه صور لمجموعه
مسلحه اوكرانيا كما ذكرنا تنشر مقطعا لهذا
العلم علم النباله وهو علم طبعا الجيش
الاوكراني
ووصلت الى تقول انها حررت هذه المنطقه كنا
قد تابعنا قبل قليل
الكرملين علق على هذه الحادثه وقال
طبعا
في وصف هذه العمليه بانها عمليه تخريبيه
وبانها عمليه كذلك ايضا
ارهابيه الكريم اللي ذكر بان الرئيس
بلاديمير بوتين الغزيره المقرره الى اقليم
ستاف روبو لمتابعه الوضع في بريانسك وقال
الكرملين كذلك بانه يتخذ اجراءات سريعه
لتدمير الارهاب الاوكراني كما ذكر في
بريان نعيد ونذكر بهذه الصور الان على
شاشه العربيه المتداوله لمجموعه
مسلحه او منظمه مسلحه اوكرانيه نشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها الظاهرين في هذه الصور
امامنا وهم يحملون علم ان بالغه علم الجيش
الاوكراني معلنين انهم قد حرروا منطقه
بريانسك وهي المنطقه الروسيه الحدوديه